l'agriculture décline tant sur les
volumes que sur nos exportations nous
sommes passés de la deuxième place de
pays exportateurs au monde à la sixième
place les explications elles sont
multiples mais en particulier il y en a
une plus que les autres ce qui nous a
incité à faire ce rapport c'est que 70%
de ce déclin est expliqué par notre
manque de compétitivité
[Musique]
pour faire ce rapport nous sommes partis
sur l'analyse de 5 filières 5 filières
qui correspondent à l'alimentation en
général de tous les Français qui ne
mangent pas des tomates de la pomme du
poulet ou ne boit pas du lait ou des
produits laitiers ou ne mange pas du
pain ou des biscuits à travers la
production de blé et nous constatons que
cette manque ce manque ou cette perte de
compétitivité s'explique par plusieurs
points une augmentation des charges qui
est trop importante en France dû à un
coût de la main d'oeuvre qui est trop
élevé dû à une sur transposition des
textes trop nombreuses et beaucoup trop
de contraintes administratives c'est
aussi des accords de libre-échange qui
viennent pénaliser l'agriculture
française ou c'est encore un principe
médiatico politique qui est sans arrêt
en train de taper sur le modèle français
ou sur la capacité de production de
l'agriculture française tout ça
conduisant véritablement à une baisse de
la productivité réalité à une baisse de
la compétitivité et qui entraîne deux
risques majeurs le premier c'est que
nous importons de plus en plus de
produits alimentaires en France donc
notre souveraineté en est attaquée et ce
qui entraîne un risque majeur c'est que
les consommateurs français se
diviseraient en deux groupes d'un côté
les consommateurs qui ont les moyens de
se payer une alimentation made in France
qui serait très fortement montée en
gamme puisque depuis quelques années le
seul remède à ce manque de compétitivité
que le gouvernement applique c'est le
tout monté en gamme et de l'autre une
autre partie bien plus importante 80%
des Français qui seraient condamnés par
un pouvoir d'achat qui n'augmente pas et
bien de consommer uniquement des
produits importés le deuxième risque
majeur il se situe au niveau de la
problématique géopolitique on le voit à
travers la guerre en Ukraine et la
difficulté d'approvisionnement sur
certains produits lorsque nous aurons
perdu une très grosse partie de notre
souveraineté et qu'on des produits qui
ne pourront plus rentrer le jour où il y
a un événement géopolitique parce qu'on
est tributaire des autres et bien on
peut se retrouver avec des Français qui
ne trouvent plus suffisamment à
s'alimenter
[Musique]
l'exemple de la pomme où on avait 700000
tonnes de pommes exportées il y a encore
10 ans aujourd'hui on exporte plus que
la moitié 350 000 tonnes on a importé
100000 tonnes de pommes il y a 10 ans on
en apporte plus de 200000 tonnes tout
cela pourquoi parce que nous avons
tellement monté en gamme que nous
faisons une bonne parfaite qui coûte
trop cher qui est à 1 euro 18 de coût de
production alors que la pompe polonaise
est à 53 centimes donc deux fois moins
cher que la nôtre et ce qui fait que les
marchés à l'export ont quasiment tous
été captés par la pompe polonaise au
détriment de la pomme française et le
paradoxe le plus général c'est que c'est
sur transposition ce sont concrétisés
par la possibilité pour un agriculteur
polonais d'avoir 450 molécules
utilisables quand le français se
retrouve avec plus que 300 molécules et
donc une diminution de sa capacité de
traiter tant les maladies que les
insectes les ravageurs et donc une
diminution de la production de façon
drastique entraînant
encore le fait que ayant moins de des
cartes triage c'est à dire de petites
pommes ou ce qu'on appelle les pommes
moches et bien on se retrouve avec moins
de capacité à faire de la compote alors
que dans le même temps la consommation
de compote pour les Français augmente et
donc on se retrouve à être obligé
d'importer un tiers des pommes qui
composent la compote une pomme sur 3 de
Pologne avec les 150 molécules qu'on a
interdit chez nous donc à se mettre
autant de barrières à se limiter autant
sur notre production non seulement on a
une culpabilité de naïve parce qu'on
fait rentrer des produits qui viennent
de l'étranger pour compenser ce qu'on ne
produit pas parce qu'on a tué la filière
et de l'autre côté on mange à traverser
importations des produits qui ne sont
pas normalement autorisés chez nous
le message que veut faire le passé le
Sénat et c'est ce que je dis depuis
plusieurs années c'est que à ne regarder
l'agriculture que par le prisme de la
toute montée en gamme est une erreur
colossale parce que on sanctuarise la
totalité de la production française
uniquement sur le haut de gamme donc on
va comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
faire que une grosse partie de la
population française sera obligée de se
tourner uniquement sur les produits à
importer moins cher parce qu'elle n'aura
pas les moyens de se payer une
alimentation plus cher le deuxième
élément c'est que il faut qu'on remette
la compétitivité au centre de nos
politiques publiques donc il faut
véritablement qu'à chaque fois qu'on
investit à chaque fois quand on vote une
loi faire attention à ne pas sur
transposer faire attention à favoriser
la compétitivité parce qu'à force de ne
pas vouloir le regarder et ben on finira
par ne plus rien produire et on sera
totalement tributaire en termes
d'alimentation de tous les pays qui nous
entourent
[Musique]